(dramatic music)
- [Announcer] From the University
of California at Berkeley.
(upbeat fanfare music)
- Welcome to A Conversation
With History, I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest is the distinguished
Japanese writer Kenzaburo Oe.
His prolific body of
novels, short stories,
and critical and political essays
has won almost every
major international honor.
Oe's achievements as a writer,
committed to both literary
and humanitarian causes
were recognized in 1994
when he was awarded the
Nobel Prize for Literature.
In works such as A Personal
Matter, The Silent Cry,
A Quiet Life, Hiroshima
Notes, and A Healing Family,
Oe's art moves from the
personal to the political,
exploring how the individual
in confronting life's tragedies
overcomes humiliation and shame to,
in his words, get on with
life, and in so doing,
finds personal dignity and a renewed sense
of his responsibility to his fellow man.
Mr Oe, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you Harry Kreisler.
- Welcome back to Berkeley, I should say.
Tell us about where you
were born and grew up.
- I was born in 1935
in a small island
of the Japanese archipelago.
Especially, I must emphasize the war
between USA and Japan
began when I was six years old.
And then at ten years old,
I saw the war finished.
So my childhood was during the wartime.
That is a very important thing.
- Were you the first
writer in your family?
- This is a very delicate problem.
My family continued to live on,
almost after two hundred
years or more than that.
There are plenty of
journalists of my ancestors.
So if they wanted to publish,
I think they could have
been the first writers.
But unfortunately, or fortunately,
they didn't publish it,
so I am the first man who
published what I write,
but my mother was always saying that
you men of our family are
always writing the same thing.
- (laughs) You have said in an interview,
The act of trying to remember
and the act of creating
began to overlap, and that is the reason
why I began to write novels.
- Yes, and if I add something,
I begin my writing
by the method of imagination,
on the ground of imagination,
and toward the imagination.
- What books did you read
as a young person that you remember?
- I don't read many books
before nine years old.
I was fascinated by the
talking of tales of my grandmother.
She was talking almost
everything about in my family
or in my district, so
it was enough for me to,
I didn't need any books on that time.
But one day, there was some discussion
between my grandmother and my mother,
and my mother got up very
early in the morning,
and she packed one kilogram of rice,
we eat rice,
and she went to the small city
of our island over the forest.
Very late at night she
returned to my village.
She gave a small doll to my sister,
and some cakes for my younger brother,
and then she take out two pocket books.
Tome one, tome two.
And I found out Mark
Twain's Huckleberry Finn.
(Harry laughs)
I didn't know the name of Mark Twain or
the name of Tom Sawyer
or Huckleberry Finn,
but my mother said , and
this was the first talk
between my mother and I about literature,
and almost the last talk between us.
She said, "This is the
best novel for a child
"or for an adult, thus your father said."
The year before my father had passed away.
"I brought this book for you,"
but the woman who made
the barter with the rice between us said,
"Be careful, the author is American.
"Now the war is going on
between USA and Japan.
"The teacher at school will
take it off from your son.
"Then if your teacher asks you
"who is the author,
"then you must answer Mark Twain
"is the pseudonym of a German writer."
(Harry laughing)
- You also read, according
to your Nobel Prize speech,
a book called The World Adventure of Nils.
- Yes, that is a Swedish Author
very famous feminine author,
Lagerlof, wrote that book,
but it's a book for the children
of Sweden to study the
atlas of their country.
So Nils, a kind of trickster
is going through all of the country
on the back of a small geese, goose.
That is also very, very fascinating.
So in my childhood only two books are dear
and also I continued to
read them again and again.
So I always remember all the,
all write of the lines of
the words of those two books.
- And one line in particular stood out,
which is this young,
person who rides the geese
to tour the landscape.
When he comes back he says,
I am a human being again.
- Yes, yes, he has become
a very small boy
by some fairy magic
so he couldn't believe
in the possibility he becomes an
ordinary sized human being.
He returned to his house,
secretly he comes in the kitchen.
His father finds him.
Then some very kind, humane
passion occurs in him,
Then very naturally he grows
to the ordinary man's size.
Then he shouts, oh Mother,
again I am a human being.
That is very important
for me to add, to me.
- You have called yourself
a writer of the periphery.
And in part, you are
referring to your origins
but you also mean more than that.
Explain what you mean when you say,
I'm a writer from the periphery.
- Yes, I believe I am,
I was born in a small island, I said that
and we are Japan,
Japanese, and our Japan is
on the periphery in Asia.
That is very important thing.
Our very
eminent colleagues of Japan
believe in Japan is the center of Asia.
And even they think secretly
Japan is the center of the world.
So I always say that I am
the writer of the periphery,
periphery district,
periphery Japan of Asia,
and periphery country of this planet.
This is I'm, with proud I say it.
Literature must be
written from the periphery
toward the center, and we
can criticize the center.
And also, our credo, or our
theme, or our imagination is that
of periphery, peripheral human being.
So the man who is in the center
who has not, have nothing
to write, anything.
So and from the periphery,
we can write the story of the human being
and this story can express
the humanity of the center.
So I think that,
when I say the word periphery,
this is most important creed of mine.
- In The Healing Family,
you quote Flannery O'Connor
when she speaks of the novelist's habit,
- Yes.
- The accumulated practice.
- What is that?
How would you explain to students
what the habits of a writer are?
- Yes, at first, the word habit
is not a good word for artist,
who are young men.
So I must use the word habit precisely
by the meaning of Flannery O'Connor.
Flannery O'Connor got that word habit
from her tutor, Jacques
Maritain, I believe.
Jacques Maritain was in
Princeton at that time.
I think Flannery O'Connor
was born, I believe, in 1935,
and shortly after the
war Flannery O'Connor
was doing conversations
through the letters with
her tutor, Jacques Maritain.
It was Jacques Maritain was writing,
or talking about the
notion of neo-Thomist,
Thomas Aquinas, was a
most important figure
for Jacques Maritain.
In the notion of Thomas Aquinas,
via Jacques Maritain, found the word out.
The habit is this,
when as a writer I
continue to write every day
for 20 years or 30 years
then gradually the habit of
a writer is molded in myself.
I cannot be conscious about it,
or I cannot be unconscious.
But anyway, I have a habit
to reborn as a writer.
So if I find out the
crisis that I have never experienced
but on this first crisis,
I can be born, or I can write something,
by the quality, by the power of the habit.
Even some soldier
or a farmer or a fisherman
can reborn by the power of the habit
when he meet the greatest
crisis of his life.
And we human beings is
being born and reborn
and we create our habits as human beings,
then I think we can face their deaths
even though we cannot experienced
it before that, before.
That must be the notion
of Flannery O'Connor,
and I am a student of Flannery O'Connor.
- For you it was, the birth of your son
was a turning point in the finding
of your voice as a writer.
- Yes.
- And in fact, you've written,
twenty-five years ago,
my first son was born with brain damage.
This was a blow, to say the least.
And yet as a writer, I
must acknowledge the fact
that the central theme
of my work throughout
much of my career has
been the way my family
has managed to live with
this handicapped child.
- Yes precisely, I wrote it.
Yes.
When I was twenty-eight
years old, I believe
my son was born.
When I was twenty-eight
years old I am a writer,
a rather famous writer
on the Japanese scene
and I was a student, I was a
student of French literature.
And I was talking in the voice
of Jean-Paul Sartre or Merleau-Ponty.
Then, I was always speaking
about everything of this work.
But when my son was born with
very big damage in his brain,
I found out one night, I
wanted to encourage me,
so I wanted to read my book.
That was the first time I read my book,
or the book that was
written on to that date,
and I found out two days later
I cannot encourage myself through my book.
Then anyone can't be
encouraged by my work.
So I thought, I am nothing
and my book is nothing.
So I am depressed very strongly.
Then I went to,
I was asked by a journalist who is editing
a political magazine in Japan
and I went to Hiroshima,
the place the atomic bomb was uh.
Then there, on that year,
the peace movement, the anti-atomic bomb
in those assemblies there was big fight
between a Chinese group
and Russian groups.
And I was the only one
independent journalist there,
so I criticized both of them.
And I found out the hospital
of Hiroshima survivors
and there in the survivors a very great
Dr. Shigeto I found out.
And with a conversation between Shigeto
and the people who is in the hospital,
gradually I found out there's something
that encouraged me, so I wanted to follow
this sense that there is something.
So I returned to Tokyo
and I went to the hospital
of my son, and I talked to
his doctors to rescue my son.
Then I began to write about Hiroshima,
then that is a turning point of my life.
A that was kind of rebirth for myself.
- And so there was an
interplay between what you saw
in the victims of Hiroshima
and also very importantly
the doctors who were treating the victims,
that somehow moved you to another level,
or another plane in dealing
with your own personal tragedy?
- Yes.
Yes, and Shigeto said to me,
we cannot do anything
for the survivors.
Even today we don't know
anything about the nature
of the illness of survivors.
And even today, so
shortly after the bombing,
we don't know anything,
but we did what we can do.
Every day a thousand people dead.
But amidst the dead bodies, I continued.
So, Kenzaburo, what can I do except that,
when they need our aid?
Then, now your son needs you.
And you must find out
anyone on this planet doesn't
need you except your son.
Then I understood it.
So I returned to Tokyo and I
began to do something for my son,
and for myself, and for my wife.
- We should say that your novel about
which involves a protagonist called Bird
confronting the birth of a child
is called A Personal Matter,
and your essays on Hiroshima
are collected in a collection
called Hiroshima Notes.
- Yes.
- Now, I want to read you something
that you say about Dr. Shigeto,
and his colleagues who
were treating the patients.
When the Hiroshima doctors
pursue the A-bomb calamity
in their imaginations,
they are trying to see more
deeply and more clearly
the depth of the hell into
which they too are caught.
There is a pathos in this dual
concern for self and others,
yet it only adds to the sincerity
and the authenticity that we sense.
So that in a way, you
are seeing this duality
in the doctor, you're
saying helped you see
the complexity of the dilemma of Bird,
the protagonist in your novel.
- Yes, yes.
I think until then my little theme
was a duality or ambiguity of human being
that came from the
existentialism in France.
But I think I found out the true duality
and how I can be so-called
authentic, authentic
but the word authenticity must
not be so liquid in my case,
but I used the word from Jean-Paul Sartre.
Any way, I wanted to be an,
if I say,
today in the other word, that very simple.
I wanted to say, I wanted to be straight.
I wanted to strictly stand up man.
Now I cannot remember which are
the important word.
Irish poet,
most important poet.
- [Harry] Yates
- Yes, Yeats said straight
in his poem,
he says about the young man
who stands straight,
straightforwardness.
This kind of erect quality
this kind of person,
this kind of young man
I wanted to be,
but then I used that word authentic.
- Lionel Trilling the critic,
wrote that confessing
to one's true feelings
was one of the most courageous
and valuable things a writer could do.
And that's what you did
in A Personal Matter.
- Yes, I wanted to do so.
But at the time I don't think about
the value of a stand up point.
But anyway, I must write about myself.
Why not?
I cannot be reborn
and my son also can't be reborn, I felt.
So when I was by the sea,
I must rescue myself and
I must rescue my son.
So I wrote that book, I think.
- And your son went on
to become a composer.
And tell us a little bit about that,
in other words, your family,
in caring for him,
your wife, your self, your children,
over time identified an ability
that he had to communicate.
Tell us how that came out.
- Until my son is four
years or five years old,
he doesn't do anything
to communicate with us.
And we thought that he cannot
have any sense of the family.
So he was very, very isolate,
he looked like very isolated boy,
like a pebble in the grass.
But one day, he was interested
in the voice of a bird from the radio.
So I bought disks of
the wild birds in Japan.
And I made a tape
of 50 specimens of the bird.
- Bird calls.
- Yeah
- And there are the bird
calls and a very flat voice,
a woman announcer, says
the name of the bird.
Tada-dada, then, nightingale.
Tada-dada, sparrow.
This is sparrow, this is nightingale.
Then we continued to listen to
that for almost three years.
And during those three
years, when we played
the bird songs, my son become very quiet.
So it was needed to make him quiet.
My wife must do her work,
and I must do my work.
So with the bird voices we three lived on.
But in the summer when
he was six years old,
I went to our mountain house,
and while my wife was
cleaning our small house,
I was in the small forest
with my son on my shoulder.
And nearby there is a small lake.
A bird sang, a couple of bird,
bird sang from the couples.
Suddenly a clear, flat voice
said, "It's a water rail."
(Harry laughs)
Then I shook, utter silence in the forest.
And so, in five minutes
or so, we are silent
and I prayed for something,
there on my head.
I prayed, that please, the
next voice of that bird
and please next the remarks of my son,
if that was not my phantom or dream.
Then after five minutes,
the wife of that bird sang.
Then my son said "It's a water rail."
(Harry laughs)
Then I returned to my house
running with my son and
I talked to my wife.
And for a long time, we
waited for another voice,
but there was not any
voice during the night.
And in the very early morning, we kept,
we didn't sleep.
But a very small sparrow
came on a small tree
in front of our window.
And he made a small sound,
and my son said, "It's a sparrow."
(Harry laughs)
Then everything began, and we found out
we played the sound of
a bird, my son answers.
And we bought many recordings of birds,
even the bird of the USA or Europe.
And my son answered very
quietly and very quickly
if he listened two or
three times the name.
Then we
began to communicate by the word.
My son is called Pooh-chan,
Pooh from Winnie the Pooh
Pooh-chan what is the bird?
And he answers, the sparrow.
Pooh-chan, what do you want
to listen to the birds?
Then he thinks, water
rail, or nightingale.
And then we play it.
Then, we began to communicate,
and my son was accepted
from the school of the mentally retarded.
The boy was retarded.
And then the teachers,
very few teachers in the school
saw they could not take care of my son.
So then, they are always
playing FM broadcasts
So they are playing Bach and Handel,
then my son began to listen to the music.
And after he is concerned with the music,
he suddenly he forgot almost
all the voice of the bird,
voices of it, name of the bird.
Then they began to study the piano,
and then he continued to listen,
but when he son was sixteen years old
he had a very strong fit and
he lost the sight of both eyes.
One of the both eyes can see,
but through both eyes, he cannot see.
So he cannot look at the
piano and the musical score.
So he make a missed note,
that is very uncomfortable for him.
So he gave up the piano
but his mother taught him
how to write the music.
Then, almost in five weeks,
he began to write Bach,
Johann Sebastian Bach, by pencil.
At first that is very simple music,
but in a year he began to compose
his music by himself.
- And now he has two CD
discs, which you just said
that you were able to buy on
Telegraph here in Berkeley.
- Yes, eighteen years ago, I was in the
Women's Faculty Club of Berkeley,
University of Berkeley,
California, Berkeley.
There I was very deeply melancholic,
and I was thinking about my son,
but now two days ago,
I was thinking about my
lecture of next Monday.
I was melancholic, and
I escaped from my room,
I went to the Tower Records
on the Durant Street,
and I bought some discs, CDs,
by Kiru Sora, or something.
Then I wanted to check.
I don't believe that my son discs,
but I wanted to check the,
old corner of the
composers, and I found out
two discs of my son, and I bought it,
and that morning I played it.
- So your son in a way has
fulfilled the dream of Nils,
riding on the wings of birds
or, in this case, their sounds
- Yes, yes, so besides the bird,
besides the big bird, my son can say it.
Yes, I am a human being, I'm a man.
And besides the discs of my son,
I thought that I'm man.
- You have written In A Healing
Family that your son's music
has shown you that in the very
act of expressing himself,
that in that act there is a healing power,
a power to mend the heart.
And you go on to say, for in the music
or literature we create,
though we come to know despair,
that dark night of the soul
through which we have to pass,
we find that by actually
giving it expression
we can be healed and know
the joy of recovering.
And as these linked experiences
of pain and recovery
are added one to another,
layer upon layer,
not only is the artist's work enriched,
but its benefits are shared by others.
- Yes, if would I add
something to my comment there.
After writing that essay, I
experienced many questions
to me, and many critic criticized me,
that Oe has become very conservative now,
and he is a very quiet man,
and he says, his music healed him
and he can be healed by the CD of himself.
But that is very negative and
very conservative, they said.
But, I must answer that.
I don't say to be healed in Japanese.
I think the verb heal
must be used actively.
You know, I heal myself, or something.
A human being is healed by something.
That is a very positive
deed of human beings.
So when I listen to the music of my son,
I don't experience any passive deed.
I feel I am doing something
positive with my son.
We are looking at the same direction.
So if someone feels he is
healed by the music of my son,
even then I believe someone, unknown man,
is looking at the same
direction with my son.
So he is positively healing
himself with my son.
- So that your son is, in his own way,
getting on with his life, as you say.
and the example can inspire others,
help them get on with their lives,
and heal themselves in the process.
- Yes, precisely, so I
want to do the same thing.
My son's music is a
model of my literature.
I want to do the same thing.
- Do you believe that a
writer chooses his themes
or do they come upon him?
- Oh, yes, I think,
Nadine Gordimer once has written
that we don't choose a theme
or a situation or story or everything,
that a theme, it choose us.
That is the goal of the
writer, in some time,
The time, the days choose us as a writer.
So we must respond to our time.
So I think, from my experience I can say
the same thing with Nadine Gordimer.
I didn't choose the story
of a handicapped son,
or we didn't choose the theme
of a handicapped boy's family.
I wanted to escape from
that if it were possible,
but something choosed
me to write about it.
Or my son choosed me.
That is only one definite
reason I continue to write.
- You go on to say in another
essay, the fundamental style
of my writing has been to
start from my personal matters
and then link it up with
society, the state and the world.
- Yes, I think I am doing
my works to combine, to
link myself, or my family,
with the society, with the
cosmos, the whole world.
So link me with me, with my family,
link my family to the cosmos,
that is easy, because
all of the literature
has some mystic tendency.
So when we write about our family,
we can link ourselves to
the cosmos, our cosmos.
But I wanted to link myself
and my family with society.
So when we link ourselves to the society
then we don't write very personal matter
but we are writing the independent novel.
- You say in The Healing
Family that the lessons
that you learned in
making a handicapped child
an active part of your family
was an example, in a way,
that teaches the individual
how society at large should
treat the handicapped,
and that society, in
essence, one can create
a healing society through
having a healing family.
- Yes, I hope so, but I don't
want to emphasize the role of the family
of the handicapped boy.
I don't want to emphasize individuality.
Always, when we linked with society,
our individual family,
has the value, social value.
So, if not, I think, we can only write
very personal matter
through our experience.
When I named my first novel about my son
A Personal Matter, that I believe
I knew the the most important thing.
There is not any personal matter.
We must find out a strong
pipe between ourselves,
and to the society.
- SO what role should the writer play
in the politics of his time?
- Yes, to combine our
service to the society,
that is politics, that is my opinion.
I don't need any role as a policymaker.
There are some friends of mine
who have become the policymaker.
- You don't want to be
Henry Kissinger. (laughs)
- I was in a seminar with Mr. Kissinger.
But Mr. Kissinger said
in the bye bye party,
with a very famous,
what is it?
Malicious smile, or something
The very wicked rabbit makes a smile
in the cartoons, like
this, wicked smile, yes.
"Mr. Oe's wicked smile,"
Mr. Kissinger said.
But I am not a wicked person, but
against the policymaker,
sometimes I make a wicked smile.
But I am not a man with a
policy, or doing the politics.
But from the real life of human being,
I want to do something for the politics.
So I must do something through
my literature or my essays.
- And what is that?
- Right now I'm actually, I personally
I believe I can say in my very small voice
now I am doing that.
(both laughing)
- What does a Japanese writer need to add
to the discourse in Japan,
given what has appeared
to be an emphasis on materialism,
and a lack of values,
which you have discussed
in some of your essays.
- Yes, I continually criticize
Japanese people's attitude in Asia,
and throughout the whole of the world.
Before the economical
supply or economical
great situation in Japan.
Before, even when we are poor
I began to criticize our attitude to Asia,
or to the all of the world.
And during the very, very
prosperity of economics
of Japan, I continued.
After that, now our crisis, we
are in a crisis of economics,
and I must continue that.
I think, in Japan,
we wanted to create a truly new
national attitude after
our defeat of the war.
For years, we wanted to do that
and we wanted to create
a democratic country,
democracy, democratic man,
but I think we gave it up.
Fifty years passed now.
There is an atmosphere of
anti-democracy in Japan.
So they don't say that, today, not yet
they say ultranationalism must be,
must come back to Japan, but
I feel it very ambiguous.
Give the dangerous
atmosphere of nationalism
is coming in our society.
So now I want to criticize
about this tendency,
and I want to do everything
to prevent the development
of fascism in Japanese society.
- Do you think that your
novels and the humane themes
that you focus on contribute
to the climate of ideas
so that fascism becomes
less of a possibility?
- Well, I think when I was
in Hiroshima, doctor said,
"When you cannot do anything,
you must do something."
So I think if I can
have some power to influence
the young intellectuals,
I think we can organize
some, a different power.
Because today's crisis
is unconscious feeling
of some ultranationalism in Japan.
A very big feeling, atmosphere.
So we must, if we write
about it precisely,
and if we attack it, then I think
Japanese young intellectuals
can become conscious about this feeling.
It is very important in the
beginning, so I want to do it.
- So in a way, these intellectuals
might confront these issues and help shape
the public debate in the way that,
in A Personal Matter, Bird confronts
the reality that he has to confront.
- Yes, so I want to
ask young men of Japan,
or young intellectuals, please
confront to your reality.
- A theme that I've noticed in several
of your books was a focus on youth.
Nip the Buds talks about a youth gang
where there are no values
and the town has evacuated, and so on.
What special role do young people
have to play not just intellectuals,
in shaping our ideas about the world?
- Well yes, now that
I finished my novel,
and in the end of my
novel, my hero is creating
a new charity, that is not
Christian, not Buddhist,
but only they are doing something
for the soul of him, of
the assembled young men.
The leader, one day read a Bible
in front of the people, Ephesians,
the letter of Ephesians.
And in Ephesians there
are two words, new man.
Jesus Christ has become
a new man on the cross.
We must take off the
old coat of the old man.
We must wear a new one.
So only the new man can do something,
so you must become a new man.
My hero hasn't any real
program about the future,
but he believes that we must
create a human, a new man.
And the young man must become new man.
Old man must mediate
to create new man.
So, that is my creed.
So, I'm always thinking
about youth's role in Japan.
- How would you recommend that students
who might see this interview,
prepare for the future?
First, how to prepare to be a writer?
And secondly to have the
kind of positive influence
in defining a new man
that you just mentioned?
- Yes, I want,
at first, I hope the young man is
uprighted, yes, and independent.
- Like Bird?
- Yes, and also, and secondly
I hope they have imagination.
The imagination is not the power
to accept the other's image
but to create our own image,
and also more precisely
to reform the imagination
which was given to us.
So to be upright and
to have an imagination,
it's enough to be a very good young man.
- You have a quote, if I can find it
when you speak of Dr. Shigeto,
and if can leave you to comment on this.
You say of Dr. Shigeto, you write,
without too much hope or too much despair,
he had simply dealt with the
suffering as best he could,
and then you go on to say, he
was truly an authentic man.
- Yes yes, so my professor
was a specialist of French Humanism,
and he always said to
me "What is Humanism?
"It is to be without too much hope
"and also too much (speaking
foreign language)",
what is the English word?
- Despair, despair.
- Despair, yes.
Not too much despair, not too much hope.
That is the model type
of a humanist today.
That was my teacher's
comment, and I said that
to Mr. Shigeto, and Shigeto said,
"Yes, I know that through my life."
- Thank you very much Mr.
Oe for joining us today
and sharing reflections on your work,
and welcome back to Berkeley,
and we hope you come again.
- Thank you very much, you
are authentic with questions.
- Thank you.
And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(upbeat fanfare music)